Using alternative therapies for cancer that is rife, supplements, diet, et cetera, and tracking my tumor markers.
How can one interpret?
I had a ten-point rise in the first two months, alternative therapy, and most recently only a five-point rise within a month.
Is that a positive improvement?
Or if the amount of increases less than previous, or is there any increase a negative sign?
Okay, so how do you interpret a tumor marker test when you're doing any type of care?
So for those who don't know who don't have cancer, tumor markers are different proteins that different cancers may or may not give off.
So let's use CA-199 as an example. So CA-199 is a tumor marker.
No, there are dozens and dozens of different tumor markers. Let's use your PSA as an example.
So PSA, more people are more aware of PSA prostate specific antigen, is a tumor marker for prostate cancer.
Now, that's only going to be for prostate cancer. So somebody is not going to have an elevated PSA with colon cancer.
But some of the other tumor markers are not as specific. So like CA-199 that I mentioned, that could be elevated with pancreatic cancer, that could be elevated with breast cancer, that could be elevated with even with colon cancer, or not, as common.
If a person has prostate cancer, 99% of the time their PSA is going to be elevated.
But if a person has pancreatic cancer, there's a much smaller percentage of the time their CA-199 will be elevated. Maybe it's 80% of the people with prostate cancer, I don't have those statistics.
But with breast cancer, there are several tumor markers. There's CA-153, there's CA-199, there's CEA, there's CA-25, 27-25.
And those should be done on every woman with breast cancer, because one woman might have an elevated CA-153, and another woman might have normal CA-153 and an elevated CA-199.
So it isn't guaranteed that your cancer, if you have cancer, that your tumor markers are going to be elevated.
But the benefit of doing tumor markers is that it gives you a non-invasive way to measure progress. If your tumor markers, if you do show one or more tumor marker that is elevated,
it gives you a more non-invasive way to measure progress of care. Meaning that, okay, I have to go get a blood draw to measure by tumor markers versus going to get a CT scanner, MRI or PET scan.
Those are fairly invasive MRI, well, you start to get gadolinium as a die, that can be invasive CT scan as radiation as well as PET scan as radiation.
And cost-wise, you know, cost you less than $100 to do a tumor marker panel, cost you $20 to a PSA test.
So it can be less invasive, you can do it on a more regular basis, so you can do tumor markers on a monthly basis.
So this question is being asked, if I have an elevated tumor, let's say this person has breast cancer, let's say their CA-153 is elevated, and as they're starting a course of care, whether they're doing standards of care, whether they're doing alternative care, the numbers are going up.
And as through that course of care, let's say it's the first two months, it's gone up 10 points.
Well, when was your first baseline? Well, you always have to get a baseline, and it's a shame that more oncologists don't run tumor markers right away with a person as a diagnosis of cancer because then they will give that person a baseline.
Wherever we draw that baseline of that first blood test, and then you're measuring subsequent blood tests to see, you know, which direction things are going.
If things are, you know, slowing down and starting to level out and starting to go down, that's what we want.
Sometimes when you start a course of care, your baseline is, let's say, whatever it is, 53 out of CA-153.
Let's say it went up to 63, then 73, and then it's down to 68, which would be a similar interpretation of this person's question.
Is that a good side or a bad side? Well, it's not an update. So, you know, you can have a five-point swing in a tumor marker test, and it doesn't give us, it doesn't tell us, well, you're really looking for a tumor marker test, is it really except for PSA, maybe.
Your CA-199-153 and 2725, is it like doubly? That's where you get conserved.
What a number goes away. That's where you start to get conserved.
What it's just crawled up and then crawled back down. We don't really know that we can assess care components at that time.
The second part of this question is, any increase in negative sign? Well, you know, you don't want your numbers to go the wrong way, but it can take time for things to change in your body to heal in your body to attack this.
I will say one of the reasons why oncologists don't like to use the tumor marker tests is they will say that they're not very accurate.
And I will give them the okay on that answer because they aren't very accurate if the person is doing chemotherapy as well.
So, what chemotherapy does is chemotherapy, hopefully, if it's working, it's going to destroy a cancer cell through a process of lysis.
So, it's going to cause that cancer cell to die quickly. And it can cause a spike in tumor markers.
So, when tumor markers were first discovered years ago, it was this huge aha moment for practice of oncologists.
We're going to use tumor markers to monitor this person's care. Probably, what is an oncologist recommending? Well, they're recommending chemotherapy.
And what was found was that when a person is doing chemotherapy and you're getting rapid death of cancer cells,
you can get a spike in the tumor markers because the cancer cells are dying and then you're spilling out this enzyme, the tumor marker.
And it will show in the blood that it's elevated and people would freak out. Oh my gosh, I'm going through chemotherapy. I'm feeling sick.
You're telling me that it's getting better. You're ready. There's two marker tests and it's doubled, tripled. This is not good. But it's a false positive.
So, when a cancer dies quickly, it can spill out more tumor markers and it can give a false positive of an elevated test.
Therefore, a lot of oncologists have scrapped tumor markers. That's why they don't run them because they're expecting everybody to follow their course of care, which is chemotherapy.
And they got tired of explaining to people that that could actually be a good sign when you get a spike of a tumor marker.
It's hard to explain that to a person when you're saying this is a good way to monitor our care.
But when you have a crawl upwards and a crawl downwards, you have to have more time to assess those numbers.
Be careful to put all your state in anything, whether it be a CT scan, an MRI, or a PET scan, or blood tests.
You want to look at trends. So, trends are the most important thing that you're looking at.
You can have these false changes, your blood changes, whether it's just taking a sample of your blood that's measuring what's in that sample.
And that can other things can cause variation of all your blood tests.
So, you want to look at things over time and you want to look at things in connection to other things.
So, any objective test that you're doing, you want to measure that with other objectives tests and with subjective findings.
So, you don't take one test and you make a clinical decision completely based upon that test.
You take that test that gives you clues.
So, terminal markers is the same thing.
My two markers going up, electives us clues. Could the cancer be getting worse?
Could we just be putting the brakes on the cancer at this point in time?
What are your other things that you're looking for? How does the patient feel?
What are their CDC and their complete metabolic panel telling us?
You know, what are, you know, has the patient's symptom changed over this period of time?
How has it changed?
So, you look at as many different markers as you can to make a clinical judgment.
And, that's how you go through the process of differential diagnosis.
So, hopefully that will help.